as the release date for The Flash draws
closer the filmmakers have decided to
spoil another major Cameo appearance
honestly it's so surprising that you
might spontaneously combust warning
spoilers ahead we're all aware that Ben
Affleck and Michael Keaton will return
as their respective iterations of Batman
and the Flash you want to get nuts
it's getting nuts but what about
Superman will any version of krypton's
favorite son have a cameo in the
upcoming Blockbuster the answer to that
question is a resounding yes but don't
expect to see Henry Cavill or Brandon
Routh in a red cape unless they've also
been cast and it's just been kept secret
that is regardless it seems that the
filmmakers are fine with spoiling the
big surprises pertaining to this movie
as documented by variety Andy musketti
has confirmed that Nicholas Cage's
Superman will appear in the flash
speaking about how working with the
actor was a dream come true for him
musketti said Nick was absolutely
wonderful although the role was a cameo
he'd dove into it I dreamed all my life
to work with him I hope I can work with
him again soon of course cage
technically hasn't played the Man of
Steel in a live-action Superman movie
prior to the flash he was supposed to
portray the Kryptonian and Tim Burton's
unproduced Superman lives which would
have delivered an interesting take on
the iconic character to say the least it
remains to be seen how the character
will factor into flash but he probably
won't be like other Supermen Superman
lives was supposed to rejuvenate the Man
of Steel in the late 1990s but the
project never came to fruition
originally penned by Kevin Smith the
story was reportedly based on the death
of Superman comic book storyline with
Lex Luthor and Brainiac set to team up
and unleash chaos Smith has discussed
the meetings he had with the studio
about the project in the past noting
that a producer asked him to include
giant spiders and polar bears as well
the script underwent various iterations
and Burton likely would have made a
different movie from the one Smith
originally envisioned however Nicholas
Cage was scheduled to play the Man of
Steel and he would have been a brooding
hero with long hair a Google search
brings up plenty of images and video of
cage during the casting stages sporting
the hairdo and iconic Superman costume
furthermore the film's entire doomed
production story is told in the
documentary The Death of Superman lives
what happened cage did get to play
Superman eventually albeit in the
animated flake Teen Titans go to the
movies with the flash though fans will
finally get to see him play the Superman
who got away the flash is shaping up to
be a Bonafide event movie that delivers
multiversal Madness the story revolves
around Barry Allen also known as The
Flash who decides to travel back in time
to prevent a tragedy but as Back to the
Future and countless other sci-fi
stories have warned us about in the past
meddling with time is a messy Endeavor
naturally Alan's plan backfires allowing
various heroes and villains from the DC
Universe to make an appearance this is
an exciting concept that opens the door
to a world of amazing possibilities but
has DC been giving fans too much
information about the flash in the
lead-up to the film's release as
previously mentioned Ben Affleck and
Michael Keaton's Batman are set to
appear and they've been all over the
trailers elsewhere it's been confirmed
that Michael Shannon will reprise his
role of General Zod from Man of Steel
and Batman vs Superman I will find him
Warner Brothers and DC Studios will
undoubtedly be keeping some of their
cards close to the vest however if
they're willing to spoil Nicolas Cage's
appearance don't be surprised if they
give away more big reveals before flash
speeds into theaters on June 16 2023
thank you
[Music]